well the time has come pauley perrette
Abby Sciuto has now left the NCIS team
on may 8th episode Abby finally decided
to pack her bags and head off to start a
new life in London after enduring a
gunshot wound and facing down the person
responsible for her attack all alone
fans have been bracing for the
characters accent for months and yet
it's still a little hard to accept that
her time on the show is through there
have been a lot of rumors surrounding
Polly barrettes decision to leave NCIS
after 15 seasons but the actor is doing
her best to dispel all of them when
Perret first announced in October of
2017 that she'd be giving up her long
lived role as a be the team's
intelligent and eccentric forensic
specialists fans wondered why she might
step away from the career making role
after spending so many years in those
Doc Martins false rumors swirled that
she was going to become a spokeswoman
for a skincare line but Barret shot down
that story right away I'm like what is
going on in a note to fans
the actress confirmed her exit but
denied the cosmetic connection by
writing so it is true that I am leaving
NCIS after this season there have been
all kinds of false stories as to why no
I do not have a skincare line and know
my network and show are not mad at me
that might have cleared some of the
bizarre rumors about her decision to
leave after all she's certainly not the
first actor to leave a hit series to
pursue other projects but the
speculations still continue this time
buzz suggested that trouble had been
brewing behind the scenes and that the
actress could no longer tolerate it
however it since become clear that
Perret departed on good terms
NCIS executive producers George shank
and Frank cardia told variety that they
had known for some time that season 15
of the series would be Pret's last and
that everyone involved on the show
wanted to give her a memorable send-off
the pair said in a joint statement from
day one she has brought incredible
passion and specificity to the role Abby
is a character that inspires millions of
fans around the world and all of us at
NCIS
are appreciative of Polly for portraying
her her at herself later spoke up to
assure fans there wasn't any drama
behind her departure as she told TV
insider I believe in God in the universe
so firmly and it just suddenly became
blindingly apparent that now was the
time after a lot of thought I decided to
announce it myself on Twitter because I
didn't want it to be turned into
anything shocking a be leaving is more
than a cheap TV Floyd her Etna Singh
from NCIS in the future
leaving ducky and mark Harmon's Leroy
Gibbs as the only remaining original
cast members but the mark she left on
the series and the impact she had on its
fans won't soon be forgotten Abby has
been this incredible role model for
young women thousands and thousands and
thousands of young women that have been
inspired by a television character and
now they truly are out there changing
the world so even though fans have said
goodbye to Abby Sciuto on the show her
cultural impact will certainly continue
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]